thanks John thanks very much I think we
will get a chance to hopefully you can
fold in the remaining part of what you
wanted to say now during this period
okay how do we do this my goodness
there's lots of you out there and why
don't we why don't we start by because
likely there have been questions
provoked or stimulated by the excellent
presentation so why don't we start by
entertaining two or three of those the
outcome tea and a half a second and then
I think we should take John up in his
offer because I know many of you in this
room have been doing things in this
regard and income and tell us a little
bit about your examples and maybe throw
a couple of questions to the panel as
well but let's start with some
clarifying questions or the like so sir
start with you and there are microphones
going around yeah okay Laura's got one
right behind you hello first of all
thank you for for sharing your expertise
and knowledge um I was specifically
wondering based on your knowledge and
your expertise so for Mike for example
and also for grant here why specifically
the people like the statistics in
Denmark why the people there are unhappy
for what were the specific reasons like
say your top three or whatever and
compared to for example here in
Vancouver why the people here are and
what are the specific reasons for why
they are unhappy and so and don't get me
wrong I'd like to know why people are
happy to but you know obviously knowing
why people are unhappy it gives us means
to move forward and do something about
it so yeah there you go both you guys
yeah in terms of the of the results that
we had by CMA as I mentioned so the
intent here was to dog
HUMINT the range of satisfaction
responses across the sea mas with the
depths of the sample take into account
the individual level characteristics as
I mentioned beyond that the question of
what accounts for these differences
across sea mas remains the open question
now John in previous work and others
have pointed the issues around belonging
there's both economic material and
probably more likely these social
factors this is a research agenda that's
before us at this point this is on good
and of course those two things are
linked the happiness and the unhappiness
I think what is what is the most
interesting to look at in these studies
is the panel studies where you follow
people over time so what we did in tower
was a one-time study we will repeat it
in two to three years the good things
about doing repeating repeating studies
is that you can see how life
circumstances changes in those effect
happiness because otherwise we have the
cause and effect issue you know married
people are on average happier but is it
because we get happy from marriage or is
it the other way around that happy
people have an easier time attracting a
partner so when you look at things over
time and they've done that in Germany
and England followed 10,000 people over
over 10 years what they can see there is
is one of the biggest drops on average
in happiness is when people lose their
jobs and income yes sends a purpose of
course loss of income but also loss of
identity it's the first question you
asked often other people so what do you
do and of course the social connections
we have at our office so so nervous yes
thank you for setting it up yes so do we
have two microphones or only one because
I've just been I sort of acknowledged
folks over here I tell you what let's
batch them then comments and questions
here there and then come on over here
and then we'll turn it to the panel okay
just wondering if any of the studies
you've done factor in intelligence and
sort of philosophical enlightenment into
the happiness factor because it seems to
me from my own limited research people
who have a higher sense of intelligence
or a sense of life and things around
them tend to be unhappier all right so
I'm just wondering like oh and of course
like if you go through a traumatic
experience how that there's recent
studies have come out that your DNA gets
imprinted with post-traumatic stress
disorder and it gets passed on to
children like generations and like
children of Holocaust victims have these
unhappiness issues and trauma that they
don't know where it comes from even
though their lifestyle might not be as
traumatic for example I don't know okay
great let's let's batch a couple of
these so Laura the woman in front of ya
right here Thanks just to echo that I
was curious and listening especially
just stats Canada how aspirations our
expectations factor and it's kind of the
keeping up with the Joneses and of
course the media plays into all this in
terms of what we hear about and
Vancouver it's largely housing prices
and affordability so it can be a
self-perpetuating cycle I think
sometimes as well versus focusing on
other things that connect and build
purpose in those sorts of things Thanks
Thank You Laura let's get the woman at
the back there
and I hope you beg my forgiveness will
come back to you and we'll get Laura to
come around there for the next batch of
questions ok you my name is Lindsay and
I work at the David Suzuki Foundation as
the queen of green and I was really
happy that you mentioned generosity as a
factor of it has a lot to do with
campaign we're launching tomorrow which
is a mental health campaign called 30 by
30 where we ask Canadians to get into
nature for 30 minutes for 30 days and I
was wondering if any of the panelists
can comment on directions of research
you might be going or if you have looked
into nature connectedness and people
understanding that connection with how
it affects their happiness we've done
for years of research from Trent
University a psychologist there that's
looked at our data when people spend 30
minutes for 30 days in nature and they
have better sleep they spend twice as
much time in nature by the end of the
program then than they did at the
beginning and less time in front of the
screen and we know that other pieces of
research so that it makes people more
generous spending time in nature reduces
crime rates and I wanted to come in on
your community garden idea I'm not sure
if you're aware of the research that
just working in the soil there's
microbes that actually yeah make your
brain release serotonin in your brain
which is another great one too but I
didn't realize the other comment about
thinking of the seasonal effect of when
people are more likely to be depressed
so thank you ok so let's let's get some
reaction from the panel related to the
questions or statements around
intelligence philosophically enlightened
aspirations including things like costs
of living or cost of housing and the
wild nature in all her her Glorian and
that connection with with social
well-being so three nice juicy questions
John why don't we start with you
the idea about intelligence and
unhappiness the long stick most
long-standing historical link on that is
Durkheim who invented sociology but he
also did his marvelous book on suicide
before the age started the 20th century
and he found universally with one or two
exceptions I don't have time to go
through people with more education were
more likely to commit suicide similarly
in our happiness modeling although
there's a positive correlation between
education and subjective well-being if
you hold everything else ignore
everything else once you put in income
and you which of course is higher the
higher your level of education and
social trust which is for reasons we
don't yet understand heavily supported
by the degree of Education then the
effective education turns negative
Durkheim's interpretation was people
with too much intelligence spent too
much time inventing problems they can
solve
and.and on the on the greenery side man
we don't have much stuff on the the
other part of you I don't my research
doesn't have anything much on the second
part of your question but on the
greenery one there's a lot of research
like the stuff you're doing almost
everywhere that a greener quieter city
with people spaces set out when I was
preparing for this one of my specific
ideas was why do we stop it's always
good to stop arguing about something and
having something positive to do it why
don't we start arguing about the arbutus
corridor and just make it the beautiful
long trail of green for bikes and
pedestrians that it could be I mean you
think about the popularity and social
importance of those tiny bits of
elevated railway in Paris and London and
in Paris in New York that have changed
those cities and here we've got the
arbutus corridor which is ten times as
long and three times as green it could
be a life changing the feature for
Vancouver and something to people from
the various parties could work together
and build rather than fight over one
more environmental point if I may catch
the next interurban the on the
environmental side it occurs to me that
the a lot of what we're talking about
here but aspirations and so on is about
social norms really you're happy when
you have social norms and obviously if
the social norms are pro-social then
everybody wins but the social norms are
enormously powerful now if there's going
to be a change in how one generation
thinks of the of it of the interests of
another one country thinks about the
interests of another it's going to be
converting these historically limited
sets of social identities which have
started at the family in the tribe and
extended and now go to the nation-state
but sell them beyond but its power of
humanity is they were able to create
larger groups that sense of us included
and it seems to be the next innovation
that will save the planet is changing
that to a more inclusive
norm that includes future generations
and everybody in the world and then
you've in fact made as it worked their
problem our problem and much easier to
get solutions and that will beat any
pattern of effects you would get from
any set of regulations and taxes on
energy use thanks John Grant and Mike
want dick take a crack at this just
picking up on the the intelligence
comments John made the point regarding
education I guess coming back and I know
it wasn't the nature of your question
but the one of the advantages of of
using the the large group data across
sea mas and so on is that the a because
when we when we compare life
satisfaction or happiness across
individuals there's always the question
about what's the unobserved
characteristics what we're not observing
issues like you're talking about when we
compare across large groups and large
samples across these cities unless one
wants to to venture out that there's
systematic differences across cities
along the characteristics that you're
you're talking about that those things
get netted out and so then then we could
talk about the other factors and that
doesn't diminish what you're talking
about but it does i think testify I
think those factors do get netted out in
the cross cma comparisons that we're
talking about on the social comparison a
couple of points looking at a recent
oecd study that was summarizing the
literature the issue of housing came up
and they made the point that there was
there's a vast literature on life
satisfaction and happiness that's
growing it leaps and bounds the issue of
housing housing costs relative
proportions of personal income spent on
housing and the extent to which that may
be impacting upon life satisfaction for
different groups in the population
particularly youth and large urban
centers i think is a worthwhile area and
i think we could go there with the data
that we have on that topic now again
something to be explored and again the
issue of absolute versus relative income
in the issues of social comparisons that
one makes on the issue of of
connectedness really brings up the this
sense of when one evaluates communities
livable communities there's a law
long history in a long tradition of
looking at the objective conditions
within a within a city the quality of
services natural beauty green space and
all of these things and then there was
always an assumption that if you had
those things that it would automatically
translate into subjective well-being of
the individual and of course social
connectedness and these other factors is
not part of that literature but from my
reading of that what you do see is
certainly that the green space issue
does translate across Mike I agree with
with with points from from from John and
grand I think what we could add is with
regard to the social comparison element
we know as Greg mentioned that we care
not only about absolute income but
relative income we look at how much do
our neighbors make compete compared to
ourselves and I think today we have an
additional challenge when it comes to
social comparison because we have better
ways of doing those comparisons due to
social media I don't know about you guys
but when I open facebook and whatnot I
get a constant bombardment of great news
that is happening to everybody else so
so my friends are getting married
they're going to Hawaii there you know
getting a's on their PhDs and so on and
i always open facebook wheel when i come
home and there's your leftovers and you
know the i need to clean and I need to
do my washing so I think you know that
unfortunately makes us evaluate our
lives poor than we actually should
because if we're constantly bombarded
with great news for everybody else we
think that's that's how their lives look
and that's not really the case so I
think unfortunately we are better
equipped or equipped with the wrong
weapon for making those social commerce
and i think that's that's unfortunate
persons are made more and more
negatively with income and material
consumptions than they are for the
social aspects of life so in fact
they're sort of positive spill overs
from happiness and social connections in
a way a positive social connections in
the way there aren't so it's one more
way in which people spend too much time
thinking about the material for their
well-being into little thinking about
the social connections thank you thanks
for that I hope you don't mind that will
a bachelor will do the same here so come
down just a little bit Laura two right
there okay and then the gentleman beside
her and then the gentleman over here and
then let's let's batch those and see how
those blend together we've already got a
nice blend of the social and the
ecological so well I'm moving in
different direction because I do believe
then happiness is personal choice it is
not related to economic circumstances or
any other sis conferences it's the way
we want to live so obviously doesn't
lead itself to very interesting research
if we stop correlating and comparing
ourselves all the time but it could
actually bring more happiness genuine
happiness to people so I'm touching on
this moral spiritual issue have you
considered looking at it happiness being
personal choice not circumstantial thank
you thank you for the questions please
in self-report surveys of this nature
very often social desirability accounts
for a huge chunk of the the dead the
dead the variance thirty to fifty
percent is not unusual can you tell us
how you handle that contaminant to your
data okay the gentleman over here was
there anybody else around on a slightly
different a track I'd like to make an
observation than a question so having
recently moved from downtown toronto to
vancouver island and given the season
wherein i couldn't help but notice in
the stats canada list of surveys the
cities with the highest happiness
ratings do
not have a professional sports team so I
was wondering if anyone's doing any
research on the correlation between
community happiness and the prowess of
their professional sports teams okay
okay let's take one more over there I
actually thought I had to do with winter
hi my name is alysia and I would like to
hear your comments about urban form and
happiness and specifically the design of
cities and the buildings in which we
live and work in Hell die affect our
happiness okay all right so thank you
for indulging that combination let's
stop there for now Sarah or Laura we've
got a couple down here and then I want
to encourage some of the folks folks
from the city of vancouver and they're
healthy City strategy to say a few words
Victor from the Dalai Lama Center folks
from can you dig it spectrum plan etc to
come forward and share a little bit of
your story but ok let's let's get the
panel's response now Mike am I going to
put you on the spot if you you start
first you know but I think the worse
some questions are Canadian exposed
should take care of but but I would like
to answer or try to answer the last
question about the urban design because
I think that is a field that has
tremendous potential of course we know
and have looked at for four decades how
do we design cities for people instead
of for example for cars which have been
done many places in the US great things
are being done now one of the places is
the University of Rotterdam where they
have looked it individually in Rotterdam
how different infrastructures correlates
with happiness or satisfaction with the
given neighborhood so one of the
findings were that you know how much
does cycle infrastructure or how much
does playgrounds how much does churches
and mosques correlate with with
satisfaction in the given neighborhood
what they found was that actually
mosques and churches and religious
tutions were one of the biggest
correlates one of the factors was there
is a large ethnic Muslim community in
Rotterdam but also importantly what
those institution do is they bring the
local community together and that links
back to what we're talking about today
but I think for planners for urban
policy makers there is a huge insight
potential there to figure out how do we
plan and build and design better cities
and the first question was I'm going to
their did not do it justice was around
spirituality personal choice and the
like you have a comment on that reality
and and and religion I think that that's
that has been debated over some time
with some different conclusions on that
one as far as I'm oriented about the the
subject is that early on that there was
concluded a link between being religious
and and happiness later on it has been
contested whether it's the religious
element of whether it's the fact that
you if you're religious once a week join
some sort of congregation and meet your
local community so you might as well
join the local tennis club or volleyball
team or someone and that brings us back
to the whole social relations issue
thank you and by the way feel free to
comment on any of the Canadian questions
because our definition of Canada
according to Peter's house key is as
Canadian as possible under the
circumstances
so you've been officially deputized
grant or John do you have comments on
those the three or four different sets
of tackle the happiness as choice and
not context earlier this year we
released a study on the life
satisfaction of recent immigrants in
Canada and what we did is you use
similar data that what we presented here
but we also match that up with data from
the world value survey and what we
specifically did is we identified from
the world value survey the country of
origins from which recent immigrants
that we had in our other sample had come
from and so from the world value survey
we said what's the average level of life
satisfaction in you know India in China
Pakistan wherever these folks were
coming from Romania and so on and we had
that from the world value survey I
actually have the slide but we won't
time sorting around for that and then
with immigrants in Canada for 10 years
or less so they had not been here for
very long we had the life satisfaction
question here and we also controlled for
six or eight other factors in terms of
income and where they were living their
health status their age their marital
status and so on and basically what we
found was that from the countries of
origin we have life satisfaction on this
tent 11-point scale that were often in
the range of four five or six out of ten
but the recent immigrants in Canada
generally had a life satisfaction score
that was around eight they looked very
much like canadians and if we went back
and said where would they have been in
their home country if they had had their
life satisfaction that they indicated on
the canadian survey often they would
have been in that the 90th or the
hundredth percentile so i guess the the
conclusion i draw from that was that
context mattered and it mattered a lot
in terms of of their life evaluations in
terms of the social desirability um I'm
not convinced by that I think that the
that people are able to answer this
question that one in seven people are
willing to answer it as six or less is
it the case that there's many many far
on
your people then are willing to
self-identify on the question I'm not
convinced by that but can I offer solid
evidence to say that that's not the case
I mean I would look to John for support
on that but I don't have a response on
that I shared grants view about the
social desirability there are a lot of
ways of cutting into it where the
ability to impose that is less on the
individual and they give consistent
results on the personal choices I've got
a slightly different take I think there
is a lot left to personal choices and
how value driven and what values there
are differ but one of the chapters in
the new world happiness report is on the
neuroscience of happiness and some of
the experiments that Richie Davidson is
reporting in that chapter are that
people can take training to actually
improve their generosity and empathy and
a variety of pro-social behaviors and
through training as little as two weeks
they end up not only changing their
behavior but changing the underlying
neural patterns in a way that lasts so
that does suggest figure you have to
agree to take the course if you like and
you know can do everything on your own
and the feature of what we're telling
you here collectively is almost
everything is better done with
cooperation and collaboration not just
personal choice by me but genuine
choices that involve ideally people more
than yourself but the argument that you
can actually change your underlying
what's called a personality in a way
that they improves your life and others
i think is is building up very fast so
thank you now panel would you mind if we
have an idea here we don't have a lot of
time but it'd be really nice to hear
like a smattering of folks who have been
addressing this this challenge for a
number of years certainly in from my
estimation a couple of decades worth of
very interesting work in looking at how
to
nurture happiness belonging and address
social isolation in our city so I'm
going to mention I've mentioned some of
them already but there's also folks here
from the Colleen with neighborhood house
from the Vancouver foundation but
Caroline do you want to say something
from the point of view of the city of
vancouver and it's what i think is
pretty glorious healthy City strategy
and then what I'll do is I think maybe
two or three minutes each and then I'll
just move around a little bit Victor
I'll come to you next and then and then
we'll throw it back to the panel if we
if we may so Laura can you get over to
Caroline or Caroline can you and the
yeah the folks that connect Vancouver
the there can you dig it project plan
spectrum many more okay Caroline hi so
um the healthy City strategy is a
strategy that was passed by council last
fall and it's a social sustainability
framework along with the economic and
ecological framework for the city to
move forward and do its planning over
the next 25 years it was I just want to
acknowledge Ali grant who is one of our
key architects on that project and the
the framework is essentially 13 goals
it's an integrated multi-sectoral
upstream strategy that looks at a good
start things like a good start housing
home for everyone making ends meet and
cultivating connections which is very in
keeping with some of the discussions
we're having here and in the framework
there are 21 targets and 43 indicators
and some of the indicators are things
like every person has four people in
their network and so one of the next
steps on this strategy is really
starting to develop an action plan and
as part of the action plan we're
really focusing on one of the primary
areas which is social connections
inclusion and belonging we had an
engagement strategy in preparing the
framework and I think that probably the
thing we heard the most from every
session we had from the majority of
participants was around feeling
connected and social connectedness
neighborliness feeling included so we're
going to be going to counsel in June
with an action plan we just this week
had a collective impact table on
inclusion inclusion and belonging and
really interesting to bring parties that
we would typically not have had
conversations with to look at how we
might be doing some collaborations in a
different way so caroline is a senior
social planner city of vancouver and one
of the major leads on this initiative
where's Allie grant are you here I know
you're there you are okay all right
doing some work with healthy cities now
do you want to talk about that i
actually just mentioned that i would be
interested if the panel or a bit later
on even I'll as well could speak to
their what you think of the relative
usefulness of happiness as a particular
framing compared to see health or green
or any of those things we know of course
that you know the happy city is also the
healthiest I did agree no city etc and
so when we're thinking about how to work
with some of the institutions that can
really make a difference in making
better cities for more people they not
be interested to hear from you in terms
of strategically the relative usefulness
of those framings okay thanks Ali Victor
down down here Victor Chan from the
Dalai Lama Center
well I have a bone to pick with John
here who's being a good friend for many
years but still I'm going to do it but
before that let's say take the point
that John said about riding an elevator
and trying to make another person in the
same elevator miserable by talking to
him or her I think that is so want me to
do that but I think that in terms of
scale it's something that is
psychologically brought it difficult to
do and we all have barriers to do
something like this on a consistent
basis now I look around me in Vancouver
and there are thousands and thousands of
condos with many many flaws and many
many people living in these poor
buildings now what if there is some some
kind of concerted effort like in my
building I live in a condo and there's a
manager in there and this manager or he
does is free to make sure that the whole
place is [ __ ] and span clean now what if
this manager also have a parallel role
which is to be a social animator someone
who instigate things in the condo where
you have 500 people living in the
building and you put in a coffee machine
for example you have regular get
together so that people on the same
floor get to meet people on the same
floor so I don't know whether this is
happening in Copenhagen and other places
but Vancouver is blessed with thousands
and thousands of these tall buildings so
if each of these tall buildings has a
social animator that will mean a lot of
social capital
being developed but this is not the bone
that I'm picking with John the food
disclosure is that I'm a groupie of the
world's most important happiness guru
datura Lama now it's been talking about
happiness for all of 81 he's eight years
old now so he's been talking about
happiness for like six decades of his
life and before him there's a guy in
India 2500 years ago who talked about
happiness also and one fundamental
inside of this kind India 2500 years ago
was equating happiness or correlating
happiness with generosity now you guys
are finding out that you know if you're
generous now you'll be happier person
but this insight has been around for a
long time so at the risk of sounding
pompous I would say that the kind of
research of unhappiness we are
scratching the surface the kind of thing
that you're doing a measuring is a bit
at the tip of the iceberg it's research
have shown for example that in the last
few decades how real income has been
increasing you know the curve is going
up but the sense of well-being the
sender happiness of people have actually
gone down and the other point about that
is that lets say if you have a
catastrophic event in your life let's
say that you lose a limb because of a
car accident your happiness go down
dramatically but after a while it goes
back to your set point
what that lady was saying over there you
know that happiness is basically a
internal thing that substantive
happiness and durable happiness is
something that at the end of the day
does not or should not depend on
external circumstances so the a lot of
things that we do to try to increase our
sense of well-being at the end of the
day we are talking about something that
we are increasing our pleasure potion
perhaps something that is akin to a
small degree of being hidden istic and
if you want something that is more
substantial than at a time right sorry
then I think digging deeper would be of
interest okay so I'm just mindful of the
clock here but I thought there was a hat
was their hand over there no Aaron not
for you Vicki one last comment over here
and then we'll throw it let's scare up a
couple more than okay pass it along to
this woman here and then to Vicki and
then back to back to the panel and
please be generous with your use of the
time speaking of generosity hi my name
is Amelia and I'm a career counselor and
I just wanted to give you an idea you
said you wanted to bring some ideas back
home we had an organization by haunted
by Brock Tully and he introduced random
acts of kindness and what he used to do
is he used to organize people together
to initiate random acts of kindness in
which you would do something and pay it
forward and then that person would also
take that idea for example paying a
parking meter and pay it forward and
that actually relates to what this
gentleman was saying is generosity
equals happiness so if we were able to
introduce an initiative where we have
random acts of kindness in the community
I think it would increase our happiness
here
and I brought Thank You Vicki hi my
works been about addressing isolation
for some of the most marginal and
marginalized sorry people in our in our
communities and what we've discovered
both using in-person connectors a little
bit like Victor was talking about who
really whose work it is to build the
networks of connection and using online
technology said a real key is about
being intentional and one of the things
I get a little bit concerned about when
there's lots of discussions certainly
about our public spaces and green and
all of that which i think is really
really critical I also think that there
is the dimension of intentionally
creating a network and maybe this is
part of where the question about you
know our choice to be happy but it's
also about some about our choices to be
connected and this is particularly
relevant as my generation is aging and
it seems to me for us to have a happy
old age all of us are going to need a
connected network so I'd like you know
if there's an opportunity for any
reflections on that and my other just in
terms of some of our own work one of our
findings around creating these connected
networks around people is the degree
that their confidence changes so their
confidence and whether that's part of
the trust that you referred to dr. hello
well or other parts but I was wondering
if that showed up in any of the work
that you're doing related to happiness
okay our time is gone by far too quickly
but grant why don't you lead off in them
go to John and then we'll let our guests
from from Denmark well I'll let John
respond to his nemesis in the second row
on on that I guess the concluding
comment that I would like to make in to
put back to the audience is that for
students master students doctoral
students who are here in the audience
that if you're looking for a thesis
topic if you're I would encourage you to
get out here and we have this wealth of
data that I've highlighted that's been
my main objective to
to underscore that and it's available in
the research data centers within the
universities here in BC and both the the
general social survey as well as the
Canadian Community Health Survey there's
a public use microdata file that's also
made available and that's free of charge
so I would certainly like to see these
data be used more extensively and
additional contributions to the
discussion and the research in this area
thanks grant John I like the random acts
of kindness notion and the notion of
intentionality is also important I think
nothing but agreement there and I keep
agreeing with Victor so II thought he
was against what i was saying and I say
I agree with Victor so there's a problem
here Victor the idea of course I
misspoke myself seriously by saying this
was a recent finding about generosity
it's only in the empirical literature
that's a recent finding it was not in
the earlier empirical literature it's
been in the in the longer literature
philosophically and then religious Modi
after all the golden rule is either
number one or number two instruction in
every religion there has ever been and
the golden rule is essentially a an
invocation about generosity what we're
finding an experimental work is a twist
on that but although generosity makes
you happy it makes you happier than you
think it will and there's a good reason
in philosophy why that should be because
if you knew it was going to make you
happy then you could accuse yourself of
doing it in order to make yourself happy
which would be selfish and you
that's all bike I'm gonna steal the
random acts of kindness idea and victors
should we call it chief social events
officer in the buildings and just
following on what John said about the
recent findings what I find useful now
and it of course it's frustrating as a
scientist to find out stuff that we've
known for years for decades of war
Bolivians but but i think the usefulness
now is that we have not precise but but
we have we have numbers we have data and
data and numbers are far more convincing
to move political decision makers and
policymakers if we bring this data
forward at least that's my experience in
Denmark about the importance of social
isolation and connectedness and so on
it's far easier to move the politician
makers and draw their attention to this
field and that brings me to to what was
raised over here is it easier to work it
was it better to work with the happiness
topic or gender or theme then say green
or healthy and my experience is
definitely yes I used to work with in
sustainability and did that for 47 years
very important field but basically
you're walking around telling people
that the world is going to end for some
reason they don't want to listen imagine
the the study that came out yesterday
was about you know which Canadian city
was the most most sustainable ones I
don't think he would have gotten the
same attention that the happiness
ranking has done happiness has a
tremendous convening power I think the
event here today is evidence of that
it's something everybody can relate to
it's the ultimate goal for most of us it
should be the ultimate goal for policies
so I think there is a different
different leverage in the happiness
agenda I also think this my final point
I think I can actually do more for the
sustainability agenda working with
happiness that I could
working with sustainability in a direct
manner I think these things that we are
talking about trying to change
motivating people to do that will also
have a tremendous effect for
sustainability thank you I'm going to
say a thank you especially thank you to
our panel in a minute but I just want to
do something because we're going to got
a few seconds less left I want the folks
in the audience in the room here today
who are who are intentionally as Vicki
said involved in nurturing happiness
belonging addressing this question of
social isolation to stand up just so
that people the rest of you can see how
many initiatives and involvement so is
that it's just a standing now so there's
a very interesting telephone call we had
last week in preparation for today in
which the I think somebody asked the
question do we are we going to have to
do lots of priming in Vancouver well
well here's your answer you we're
bursting with abundance here the mighty
streams and it may very well be that the
advice we need to take is the advice
that is offered in John's observation
that a critical factor in happiness is
our ability to to collaborate to work
together and so I have one more question
those of you who are in the audience who
would like to engage more in this topic
would you please stand all right that
that's most of you and and since you're
since you're standing would you join me
in a standing ovation to our three
panelists
you